this is iman rashid and he's a martial
artist
he's the head instructor at quest
martial arts school and contributor to
the modern martial arts youtube channel
with 15 years of training under his belt
we wanted to know what he thought of the
over-the-top climactic fight from yakuza
kawami
if seeing experts break down and
reacting to stuff is your thing
well we have quite a few of those on
this channel so consider subscribing to
see more of those
alright iman take it away oh is that
yakuza
dude my god that's made me so happy i
love these games
oh okay i'm gonna pause that
um ow okay uh
yeah that's super not okay a lot of
schools
don't allow leg locks because of how
dangerous they are
so um like grabbing someone's leg and
like twisting it in a certain way
i'm gonna say in like the ufc or the
kickboxing championships but you
definitely can't do that you can't just
grab someone's leg
and elbow it straight down which is
already an illegal move
and break their leg you know the other
way what i find just weird about that is
that uh
the other guy had his knee clearly bent
so his knee was bent and once you bend
your knee it makes a stronger
point for your knees you know less less
damage you can take on your kneecaps
uh because when it's straight it's like
it's right about to like like break the
other way
so i find it funny that his elbow is so
strong that it can
force the kneecap to go down and break
the entire leg
which i've never seen before or i've
never heard of happening or i don't know
if that works but
definitely illegal just breaking
people's legs in half like that by
striking it oh boy
it's so cool
okay i'm gonna pause there
that was i've never seen that i've never
seen a double
hook punch i'm sorry i'm laughing
because one of my students um
he he he makes up moves because you know
he's a kid and he's like this is called
the double
like knockouts where you take both your
hands you go like this
i'm just thinking of him now and now i'm
laughing um but uh
i've never seen like a double hand like
this
gosh i don't even know if that's illegal
that's just something i've i don't know
if you can even pull it off because like
what if you miss
like if you miss you're gonna punch
yourself in the fist and probably pretty
hard because you're trying to
kick in the person and then he used the
grip fist hands to slam the person's
head down
beneath that's hilarious so you're
saying you can't do that
i'm saying that it's so obscure and such
a weird thing that i don't even know if
they have
considered that you can't do that maybe
someone in the comment section would
know so you know let us know
i would love to be educated
okay paul's already palm treks are great
because um
i don't know if you've ever punched
someone or something but it freaking
hurts you know your your knuckles
hitting something you know most people
don't have conditioned knuckles
and even if you do have condition
knuckles it still hurts after a while of
you know punching someone
but the palm is just you know it's just
softer it hurts you less
and it hurts the other person less too i
think it's a good one to we we teach the
kids for like
you know school bully self defenses you
don't want to punch someone because that
can do some damage but a palm strike is
more
like it still will have an impact but
it's a little bit more peaceful like it
won't like give anyone a black eye or or
too much of a bruise it's just
uh softer but there's less reach you
know this is the extent of my palm
if i make a fist now my reach is like
you know like a maybe one or two inches
more and that that one or two inches
makes like a huge difference even
without the conditioned knuckles
some people they don't have tight wrists
like um when i first started punching
bags when i was a kid
with the bare knuckles i would
constantly like like
my knuckles would roll and like my fist
would do this
and do this and do this and it took a
while for me to like strengthen my
wrists to be able to
punch every time without rolling my
fists at all so yeah it's just punching
is hard people think it's easy
it's not it's actually really hard to do
okay i'm gonna pause there was a leg
kick that just happened where he kicked
the guy
behind his leg that's fine in mma like
if they exposed the back of their leg to
you and you kick it that's okay just
usually
your opponent wouldn't expose the back
of their legs
to you because it's such an easy target
to kick and there's a lot of tendons
there and if you drive your shin
right in uh that'll hurt a lot so
that'll like give you a dead leg
but i don't think it takes much to pop
in someone's knee if it's
fully extended because when someone's
neat legs are fully extended it's
already at like a point where like
there's so much pressure on the knees
already because the weight of your body
is on the this is the kneecap right here
right
there's already so much pressure because
the person's standing you know on their
legs
so all their weight is you know on their
legs so just by popping it in
you know using a little bit of force and
having that
fulcrum there um i guess it's like it's
like highly it's probably pretty easy to
collapse it down
it's really easy to do a lot of messed
up stuff in fighting it's just what
usually stops us from doing it
is like our own human decency like i've
never personally
broken anyone else's arm or like like
snap anyone else's uh
like ligaments in a smash before i've
just heard from like
certain people or like uh just um people
in the army or people who uh
you know have been through that it's
like apparently it's a really
traumatizing experience
and to break someone's arm like you have
to like
like it's it's almost like a the same
mentality of like
uh jumping into like an ice cold pool or
like i don't know
doing something where you're like okay
like like i'm gonna do it like on the
count of three like like one two three
no i can't do it and like it's it's just
apparently it's the same mentality as
that where like you have to kind of
like like really get in the headset of
doing it and just kind of
pull out that like aggression in you and
just break the arm
because apparently that stuff like
hearing the bones crunch
and like and then hearing the person's
scream
twisting their arms apparently it just
it messes with your mind it's like
it's something that sticks with you you
know for for maybe like
the rest of your life or or a good
amount of time um
it's such a messed up thing to do
okay pause uh you can't stomp if you're
stomping on your opponent
there's a lot of weight there a stomp is
really effective and practical in
self-defense
um because you're putting all your
weight down into your foot and like not
only is gravity helping you
but your own body weight is going on to
that foot there so it's it's very
illegal
because it's just a very painful painful
and easy move to do
don't stomp people thanks for watching
if you guys want to find me you can find
me on instagram at velocity i know it's
spelt weird uh you can also check out
the modern martial artist youtube
channel where my friend david does a lot
of breakdowns of
boxing matches and actual you know
matches in real life
i've helped out do a few breakdowns
there myself and if you guys really want
you can purchase mortal weapons
it's a graphic novel that he and i wrote
it's about actual
usable fighting techniques that you can
use
all crafted into a story of a man who
travels across the world to fight
worthy opponents and let us know in the
comments down below if there's anything
else you guys like to see
any questions you guys have um or
anything you guys have to suggest i'm
always open to learning as well so
all right thanks guys i'll catch you
later
kurt here producer dude of this video i
just wanted to jump in
super quick and thank you for taking the
time out of your day
to watch this video if there's any
suggestions any other clips or just more
yakuza you want to see reacted or
broken down drop them in the comments
below i read all of them
and i take all the suggestions into
serious consideration and if you just
want to see more of stuff like this in
general
let me know say that too okay i'll let
you get on with your day
thanks again see you later be cool and
stuff
all right bye
[Music]
you